so it used to be like five years ago the
idea was you do your thing we do our
thing we don't bother each other that
was called tolerance you want to dress
up like a woman fine
now the rules have changed completely
worship me as I dress up like a woman or
I'll Crush you
that's why suddenly everything even beer
cans are celebrating and promoting
transgenderism Bud Light has just
released a commemorative can celebrating
a man who dresses up like a woman his
name is Dylan Mulvaney here's a listen
Alyssa heinershide who brags that she is
the first female VP of Bud Light
telling us that Bud Light loves
dylmulvaney but hates its own customers
so I had this super clear mandate it's
like we need to evolve and Elevate this
incredibly iconic brand what does evolve
and elevate mean it means inclusivity it
means Shifting the tone
is having a campaign that's truly
inclusive and feels lighter and brighter
and different and appeals to women and
to men and representation is it sort of
the heart of evolution you've got to see
people who reflect you in the work and
we had this hangover I mean Bud Light
had been kind of a brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach
out of touch Freddy and out of town is
there anyone more out of touch than that
woman
is that woman the perfect physical
embodiment of the problem in America
yes how do people like that take charge
of our country the least impressive the
dumbest the most reaction the people who
live in the tiniest Little Worlds they
run everything people who drink Bud
Light are not impressed is the truth
John rich is one of them he's of course
a famous singer-songwriter a country
star joins us tonight with his thoughts
on Bud Light going trans
uh Jonathan I appreciate your coming on
tonight what do you make of this
well you know there's a lot of smart
really high paid people Tucker that sit
around big conference tables at all the
major brands and they spend millions and
millions and millions of dollars to
Market their product to do what to sell
more of it whether it's beer or country
music or a pickup truck or pretty much
anything you can think of and it's their
right to Market it however they want
they're making a bet that this is going
to sell more product and so you know I'm
also in this world you know I sell music
I've read Nick Riviera is a brand of
mine that's Nationwide I keep it real
simple I go God family and Country if
you love God family and Country you'll
probably love redneck Riviera and it
probably won't disappoint you and what's
what's happening Tucker is people that
have been loyal to brands for decades
and decades are finding it hard to stay
loyal to them and so they start hunting
down other brands that they can go
support and there's tons of up and
coming American brands out there that
people are flooding to right now kind of
like mine
so you really gotta hope and I you know
I it's not even owned by the Bush family
anymore but that Bud Light fails over
this I mean I don't want to be mean I
don't root for bankruptcy but in this
case I think we have to hope for that
I think the customers decide customers
are King so I own a bar downtown in
Nashville called redneck Riviera and our
number one selling beer up until a few
days ago was guess what Bud Light that
was the number one beer we got cases and
cases and cases of it sitting back there
but in the past several days you're
hard-pressed to find anybody ordering
one so as the business owner I just go
hey if you guys aren't going to order it
we got to put something else in here and
at the end of the day that's capitalism
right Tucker that's how it works that's
right and they make great targets you
hit a Bud Light at 50 yards with a 223
and it just explodes so I recommend that
uh strongly John Rich great to see you
tonight thank you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight